dirk nowitzki with the tweet yesterday
came home from china to all these
cameras at the airport I thought to
myself man I still got it turns out they
were there for Zeke and Ezekiel it made
the grand return yesterday from Cabo
Chris Sims in word just broke yeah
moments ago courtesy of ESPN confirmed
by NFL media everybody's going to be
confirming and reconfirming it none
confirming it the six-year extension for
Ezekiel Elliott is done look we knew it
was moving in this direction yesterday I
was told early afternoon there was
already talked that it was done six
years ninety million and that's exactly
what it is six years ninety million gets
up to 15 million dollars a year on
average they came back yesterday Texas
his agent Rocky Arseneau told reporters
it's very very close they just had a few
look a deal like this is complicated
yeah I'm sure you got some things you
got a button alright and there's always
gonna be that that last little victory
yeah you want to get one you want to
justify your existence as the agent or
as the person negotiating on behalf of
the team just that extra little thing
extra little pop and somebody blinked
they found a win-win they got it done
and now Zeke will be at practice today
and the question is will he be ready for
Sunday yeah well we'll unpack this as we
start the show but I mean I'm pumped as
a football fan I mean come on nuts and
bolts of things right I mean that's I
because there's so many things I do want
to talk about it is interesting and it
looks like Zeke did something that was
fairly team friendly here with the
structure of the deal at least just at
first look of it but I'm pumped as a
football fan I mean I think we both
agree Dallas Cowboys are a team that has
a Super Bowl roster yeah we questioned
Kellen Moore at OC and all that but Zeke
is the man for that team at running back
and now this squarely puts them in that
Super Bowl conversation we have no
doubts and now Jerry's off the hook
because he can go up nope I paid
everybody we're there we're ready to my
leg not everybody but at least they're
there for the most part and and the next
guy the watch is gonna be dak Prescott
because there are people who think that
whatever the best offer is that's on the
table as of Saturday
take he's not gonna play this year for
two million dollars with what what else
happen
yeah they're all right we got two hours
of pro football talk live from Chicago
it starts right now
[Music]
it's a Wednesday edition of pro football
talk live and here we are in Chicago for
the rest of the week and I love Chicago
I do it is awesome here definitely one
of my top three cities and man and we're
here for obvious reason tomorrow night
the Packers and the Bears get together
at Soldier Field to start the NFL's
100th season but the big news look we
got to get right to it this is fresh off
the presses and I first caught wind of
this yesterday that a six-year 90
million dollar extension for Ezekiel
Elliott was done if not close to being
done I was then told by someone with
direct knowledge of the negotiations it
was close Elliot's agent rocky Arseneau
later said on the record to reporters
when Elliott returned from Mexico the
deal was very very close now it's very
very done six year ninety million dollar
extension 15 million dollars per year
average in new money you throw in what
he was already do to make he's due to
make 12 million over the next two years
it's about twelve point seven five
million per year at signing which is a
lot yeah but he is committed to the team
right for eight years okay they're not
committed to him right for eight years
he's committed to them for eight years
that is a hell of a commitment for a guy
to make I mean especially with salary
cap going up yeah market changing right
more dollars available from TV etcetera
eight year commitment a lot to do but it
gets him to the number that he wanted to
be a dad some of the number he wanted to
be at he wants to be a Dallas Cowboy I
to that rule II do believe that and Mike
you and I both know this the the
contracts really about the first three
years I mean really and what kind of
money is he gonna see within those first
three years that's all he's really
concerned about at this point I mean
really he just wants his big payday for
three maybe four years he's hoping and
then we'll see where he's at
body-wise wear-and-tear you know all the
car crashes we talk about the style play
in which he runs between the tackles so
that is really the big thing but III
still kudos to Zeke Elliott for like I
said at base value looks like he did
something good for the team kudos to the
Jones family I mean I think they've
really realized and a little
like Matt Lafleur yesterday would like
the audible thing where he tells
everybody had to audibles there because
it takes the pressure off of him now
it's all air it's in there Roger's court
you got the audibles let's see how the
offense goes Jerry Jones I feel like
it's the same way he's going yeah okay I
got the team out there so it's not my
fault nobody's gonna blame me if we
start out all in one or oh and two and I
think at the base level he kind of is
happy to get that pressure off himself
to you know Krista this is where they're
gonna end up anyway why not get it done
before training camp why not engage and
treat the start of training camp as the
deadline so your guy is fully prepared
because even though Elliott will be
there and he will benefit from Wednesday
practice Thursday Friday all the
preparation he still hasn't been around
the team yeah since the offseason
program now he was there for the
offseason program a lot of holdouts the
guys not there at all right he had the
benefit of the early installation of the
Kellen more often so he's not coming in
completely cold right but Marshall Faulk
who's helped train a Zico Elliott
recently said there's no substitute for
contact he's got to get himself he's got
to get that callus Jim Harbaugh calls it
the calluses yeah he's got to get that
callus back on his body quickly and it
could cause some issues early in the
year yeah and if he gets injured you
know what if he you know what we're
gonna say no there's no doubt yeah I
mean you're right okay but it's a
dangerous position and and I don't
expect to see Keala to be like 100%
hitting on all cylinders the best
running you back in football week one
without any live contact drills or any
carries and like you know team on team
scrimmage scenarios again we've talked
about this a lot with different running
backs and levy on bail last year
especially it takes a few weeks to get
into football shape I can you can push
sleds and run wind sprints and do all
the conditioning you want but when you
have to break a tackle from you know
Fletcher Cox and then Juke out Bobby
Wagner and then run for another 20 yards
after it that's a whole different type
of shape along with the intensity and
everything that goes along with it so I
think they would be smart with Ezekiel
II at week one I would hope they don't
run him 25 30 times I think they have a
little plan to kind of get him in shape
like Jerry said what did Jerry just tell
us last week okay don't break from what
you said Jerry okay what is it you
remember he goes I want him for the
playoff stretch okay so now you got him
don't forget don't overuse him right
away I know that wasn't what he was
talking well it's all true
right shouldn't matter don't wear his
butt out and week one and two let him
get ready for the season a little bit
when I got Tony Pollard ready to go
right on your fantasy team I was excited
until until the exciters knew I was
talking about this earlier on radio Zeke
not being signed yeah was so good for
business
it really was like I was hoping this
would last another day or two because I
look at the stories every day the roof
everybody wants to know what's happening
to Zeke well now he certainly wasn't
you're writing that they're shooting you
no no they want the information about
the writing but yeah it was it's a big
story I mean people are interested in
the Cowboys they are still America's
Team you know they've been to a Super
Bowl in 24 years and the Zeke is the
straw that stirs the drink says straw
has been reinserted into the drink and
Zeke Elliott is back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports